[Music]
our top story at six several sets of
remains found at Lake Mead identified as
one missing man I'm Brian Loftus and I'm
Denise Valdez let's get right out to 8
news now investigator David charns with
what we know tonight David
Brian Denise we've learned that this man
is believed to have drowned while
fishing some 25 years ago that is
according to documents we found earlier
today the coroner's office confirming
52-year-old Claude penzinger disappeared
at the lake in 1998. several sets of
remains including portions swimmers
found in this video just last July are
confirmed to be him the news now
investigators learning pensing or was
out fishing with his brother they were
on two boats they were out separately
when Claude disappeared Park Rangers
later finding that boat unoccupied not
far from where these remains were just
found last summer now I recently asked
the coroner about this identification
process which as we can see can take
some time
is it fair to say that the DNA tests so
far have turned up no match it is still
being processed so again you're only as
good as what you can compare to what is
the difficulty in solving these cases
the challenge in solving cases is that
we're really only good at the
information that exists for us to
compare to
now the coroner's office continues to
work to identify the remains found in
this Barrel last May a big story making
news Nationwide worldwide as they use
that was investigators first reported
Metro suspecting that Mann was murdered
sometime in the 1980s now the coroner's
office is working to identify him he is
the first case in these cases we've seen
at Lake Mead they've taken DNA from
several family members of course we
don't have an identification yet but
tonight this family finally having
closure in this case some 25 years later
live tonight I'm David charns 8 News Now